as the 2024 campaign kicks into high
gear on the GOP side there's a burning
question that remains what exactly is
Joe Biden running on the economy is in
danger of recession his foreign policy
blunders have created an America with
less power and influence while Unholy
alliances led by China keep growing and
oh yeah the massive corruption engulfing
his presidency shows no sign of abating
watch this remarkable moment from the
White House briefing yesterday
there's one committee trying to get an
FBI file alleging that President Biden
took bribes there's another IRS
whistleblower whose alleging there's a
cover-up in investigation amid all of
this there was a Harvard Harris poll
this month that found that 53 of the
public including a fourth of Democrats
leave quote Joe Biden was involved with
his son in an in an illegal influence
peddling scheme there's of course
evidence that the president interacted
with his relatives Associates from China
Mexico Kazakhstan Russia and Ukraine so
what do you say to the majority of
Americans who believe that the president
is himself corrupt
wow
president the president the president
spoken to this
the president has spoken to this uh and
there's nothing to these claims
I don't know if you could hear it but
off camera as Kirby was trying to figure
out how to answer that devastating
question a stunned kjp reportedly took
the lord's name in vain
but beyond the incompetence and the
corruption there's another question
where is Joe he's running for
re-election but he hasn't even held a
campaign event yet
we did finally find him today taking a
quick trip in Colorado
thank you
remember how the media reacted when all
Trump did was walk gingerly down a
pretty steep ramp at West Point
president Trump is facing some new
questions about his health after an
unsteady walk down a ramp new questions
about President Trump's Health after his
visit to West Point the event sparked
some concerns about the president's own
health it took him 10 minutes to walk
down a ramp in the shuffle that alarmed
a lot of people around the country he
says what's wrong with the president of
the United States
what's wrong with the president he
didn't want to slip on a ramp Steve are
you going to ask the same thing about
Joe now that he's fallen and can't get
up
by the way Joe also criticized Trump for
walking down a ramp
look at how he steps to look how I stand
Watch How I run up ramps and he stumbles
downrange okay come on
look how Trump walks up the stairs and
now look how you walk up the stairs I
could do this all day long
Biden's stumbling on the stage is
actually the perfect metaphor for his
stumbles in the debt ceiling debate his
bumbling negotiating tactics months ago
now has America at the brink of default
the man who was sold to us as a master
negotiator because of his many decades
in the Senate has been largely AWOL but
in spite of Joe Biden the deal is
actually still getting closer to his
desk hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else